Speaker 1: One little story about projection
that I want to tell you about. One of the really
popular storylines from the American right
wing for more than a decade now. I remember
Rick Santorum talking about this maybe in the
Bush era, certainly early in the Obama era
is the story that they tell where they claim
the left is indoctrinating our children. They,
of course, more recently talk about the
left indoctrinating children in elementary
school. For a while, they've been arguing and
claiming not very convincingly, I might add,
that college and university are nothing but
left wing indoctrination. At the same time,
it is they who are overtly, truly, overtly
trying to indoctrinate our children. There is
a publication called The Kids Guide. I don't
totally understand whether Mike Huckabee,
the former Arkansas Republican governor, is the
publisher of this nonsense or just a spokesman.
But the kids guide, as it says, and you can see
it on the screen if you're watching today, will
help your kids learn the truth about President
Trump and to celebrate America with a free,
patriotic gift bundle. And you sign up for this
thing and it's sort of free, except you've got
to pay shipping and handling, I guess, for each
of the items that they send you. And then based
on what some people told me, it's only free for
the first month. Then you've got to pay 20 bucks
a month. That on and on and on. This is overt
right wing propaganda. Oh, yeah, here it is. You
can get a new kids guide every 3 to 4 weeks for
2190 each. And then you get. The magazine alone.
Four 795 And it's all it's all created. So it
is another one of these rifts, but it is another
indoctrination. Here is a little clip here. Yes.
As you can see, you just pay a dollar each for
shipping on this stuff. Okay. Here is a little
clip from an ad for this very same kids guide.
Speaker 2: Hey, parents and grandparents,
as we wait to see what's next for
President Trump. Mike Huckabee's education.
Speaker 1: Comes as we anxiously wait. Oh,
and I guess it is Huckabee's company.
Speaker 2: Huckabee's education company
wants to help your kids learn all about
President Trump's greatest achievements
during his first term. That's why we're giving
away the kids guide to President Trump for
free. This fun kid's guide will help your kids to
understand everything President Trump has already
accomplished for America. What's more, it's part
of a very special gift bundle that includes a
Free Kids magazine and a free video lesson, too.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is the indoctrination. And,
you know, I don't know whether I would call
it funny. It's actually really sad and scary.
The indoctrination that they worry about
from the left, especially in college, is
being indoctrinated into critical thinking media
literacy. These are not actually indoctrination.
These are some of the most important tools.
Critical thinking isn't a belief system. It's
a framework and a set of tools to figure out for
yourself what you should believe and what you
should not believe. And. I mean, give them some
credit. The right seems to accurately realize that
when you give people those tools so that when they
hear abortion is murder, supply side economics is
good. There is no such thing as climate change.
People can think for themselves and evaluate
and say, Hey, you know what? Let's actually go
on Google Scholar and search for peer reviewed
studies on that thing that they're telling me.
And let me figure out for myself what's true and
what isn't. When I hear a media message, let me
think through what are the biases of the platform
on which I'm hearing this? What are the biases of
the host that is telling me this? Those are tools
which don't lead to right wing nutter. In fact,
they prevent it. And so to the extent that the
right wing recognizes that critical thinking and
media literacy and epistemology will hurt their
movement, they are activating against it. But
it's not indoctrination. It's not indoctrination.
And they seem to know in order to survive as a
movement, they need to lie to people and tell them
College will indoctrinate you well. College will
teach you to think for yourself something that is
not particularly revered among this movement.
Send me your thoughts. Find me on Twitter at
D Pacman. Remember that The David Pakman Show
is, of course, an audience viewer, a listener
supported program, primarily through something we
call membership. You can sign up at join Packman
dot com. Not only do you directly support the
work that we do at very reasonable rates, I
might add you also get an extra show every single
day called The Bonus Show. You get the commercial
free audio and video streams of the show every
day, as well as invitations to our members only
town hall events, the last of which was it's been
about four weeks ago or something like that will
be scheduling the next members only town hall
very soon. Sign up at join Packman dot com.